Are you familiar with the Primal Trust Program where you train your brain and
make a nerve, your cells will transform from being shut down for safety to
open it up to detoxify, you know, of any, to know of other programs to consider.
So the Primal Trust, if you look it up, we've had somebody else ask me this question
a few months back. I looked it up. It's kind of, I just did not crazy about it
because it's kind of a new age type approach to, you know, call me, you know,
that's just not what I'm into. We have some patients that are into yoga and
deep meditation and all that kind of stuff, but I don't judge you for doing that.
That's not where I'm at from a spiritual perspective. So that's not something I would do.
It's, you know, they make a lot of claims and so just be careful of that. I do give
on our website on the blog post. I have links to it on the member site and on
different courses, information about parasympathetic stimulation and sympathetic nervous system
calming. Those are neurological functional neurology exercises to do that would take up,
you know, a good half hour of your day if you're going to do that on a daily basis.
I think that's going to have a greater effect to stimulate vagal nerve function,
to stimulate cranial nerve tend to stimulate your parasympathetics and to call me or sympathetic
your opposite of that. So I think that would be a better thing to do.
A chat question I've looked into retrading the brain.com. Not new agey. Okay, that's a new thing.
There's all sorts of different brain exercising programs out there. I mean, I have a degree
in functional neurology as well. I used to do a lot of functional neurology.
We used to do we actually an old neurofeedback center where we did neurofeedback with brain
ministered or feedback. It can be extremely beneficial, but that's neurofeedback with neurofeedback
equipment. It's not new age or anything. Functional neurology is just straight an anatomy
understanding neurology and how neurons work and how you can calm down different things and stimulate
other things and understanding the metabolic activity that goes on with their transmitters.
So there's there's brain centers that are out there typically geared for 80 to 80 HD.
Kids in learning disabled kids, dyslexia, etc. That can be extremely beneficial. We used to work
with a lot of kids with those types of conditions that were on the spectrum and it can be extremely
beneficial. I will say that if getting a handle of your neurology with anxiety and having to deal
with hypersympathetic stimulation, and just don't know what that means yet to understand the
difference between parasympathetic and sympathetic. So look at that blog post, go to the
underclinic.com search for parasympathetic and you'll get a video that describes what we're talking
about here. But you do need to deal with inflammation in the brain if you're like I just cannot get over
this obsessive compulsive issues that I have, this anxiety issues that I have.
If you're dealing with those neurological issues as you have a conscious awareness that that
exists in going on in your life and that this has been an issue for a long time, you have to look at
sources of inflammation. So I'd also recommend the video that is called Neural Inflammation. If so,
if you search on the Connors Clinic website again, I also have that video posted on multiple courses.
It's called Neural Inflammation, Neural Inflammation is what you'd want to search for. You'll get a 30-minute
video talking about microglial-tributed Neural Inflammation. There's a lot of people that have
Neural Inflammation, which ends up causing hyper-sympathetic tone for them to be stuck in. So they're
stuck in a hyper-sympathetic tone, meaning they're constantly anxious or just can't settle down,
can't let things go. They have OCD issues. Those can be due to all sorts of things that that
condition can be due to all sorts of things, but it's certainly due to increase inflammation of
the brain and increase glutamate in the brain, and there's ways to deal with that from a functional
neurology's perspective. I have downloadable PDF sheets on parasympathetic stimulating exercises
and a downloadable sheet on exercises that could help calm the sympathetic response, but also dealing
with it from a Neural metabolic standpoint of decreasing the inflammation of the brain,
and the inflammation of the brain can be increased by all sorts of different triggers that can
stimulate increase inflammation of the brain. Toxicity issues, post-concussive issues, food
sensitivities. So if you have a lot of food sensitivities, it's going to cause inflammation in the
body, and it's going to cause inflammation in the brain. So that's where healing the gut is so
important as well. So dealing with those things is important. So I implore you to watch that video
called Neural inflammation, and you can look at the blog post, go to colorspletic.com and look for
search for Neural inflammation, and you'll see that video that will help that. Also search for
parasympathetic and you'll see the blog post in the video that explains the difference between those
and downloadable sheets on how to stimulate your parasympathetics and calm your sympathetic.
Those are real life things that really do work that are straight neurology and they don't have any
spiritual connotations to them.